Hello, Dr. Cutters. I suffer from chronic Lyme and I have for many years in the last month
added the significant breast pain to my other symptoms. I ask what this is about, but it's the
cause. Thanks a lot for your answer. So breast pain in itself would it be necessarily a common
issue from Lyme disease. So then you've got to go why do you have breast pain? So you've got to
remember sometimes when we have an issue like even like cancer. So let's say you have breast cancer
and now you're having pain in your gut because that media metastasis to the gut. Do you mean that
gut pain is tied to the cancer? And it certainly is a question that we need to ask, but it's
common that when we have a serious already diagnosed condition like chronic Lyme that we
want to attribute other morbidities to that disease and it's not always fair. Now of course
everything is tied together at your body. So if you have chronic Lyme and inflammation from that
chronic Lyme could that inflammation be affecting the breast? Why certainly it could. But if this is
something new that you've had like this, I don't know who asked this question, but it sounds like
whoever asked this question has had chronic Lyme for some time. And now as a new symptom of breast
pain, I would investigate that. Now usually I would say usually we'll underline that word. If a person
has breast pain, that's a side of inflammation or some sort of inflammatory process going on
at that spot where the pain is. Usually cancers don't cause pain, but inflammatory breast disease
and inflammatory breast cancer can. So I would certainly get that checked out. If you're not inclined
to do a mammogram, I would definitely do a thermography to get that that spot checked out and see
what's going on. If you're palpated, you don't palpate any lumps or anything, but there's a specific
spot of pain. I don't know. This is all the question that was asked. I'd be asking the question if we
were communicating one on one, is the breast pain in a certain spot? Can you point to that spot? Or is
it in both breasts? Equally, is it cover the entire breast or both breasts? The more
diffuse the pain would be the more I would think that it's due to just general inflammation.
Some tests that you could do, I already mentioned a mammogram or a thermography. Other tests for systemic
inflammation would be to do a complete metabolic panel and a CBC yet just some blood work done to see
if there's, make sure you're including C-reactive protein and some inflammatory markers in that panel
so you can see if there's a source of inflammation. If it's been going on a few months,
could it be an infection? Yes, a chronic infection can last months or years. Typically,
that will show up on a CBC. You'll see it elevated by blood cell count. So those are some things that
you want to investigate. So like anything, when you have symptoms, symptoms are a sign of something
going on. So you always want to ask, what is this a sign up? What is my body trying to tell me?
How do I dig to get to the root cause of this? That's how you want to correct it. So you always want
to look at, okay, what is this? Is this caused by my Lyme disease? Is this caused something else?
You want to figure that out in order to treat it properly and to give your best chance to have you healing?